often times what people have to get
better at is not taking the first answer
for what it is when you say it's really
interesting to know why you're actually
looking for a new role when you've only
been there for seven months and they'll
go I'm just curious to know what's out
there it's like you're not curious to
know what's out there you wouldn't be on
the phone to me if that was the case and
then just really trying to dig into that
so I said I'll say is there anything now
in your current role that you change and
then you they start to stay stuff where
you're like ah so that's what it is
they've not mentioned at all before that
they go into office 5 days a week and
all of a sudden they're like I've got a
wife now and I'd quite like a bit more
of a flexible rol you never said that
when I asked what what you'd want so and
had a good question I always think to
ask when you're asking them what they're
looking for is there anything that I
could put in front of you right now that
you wouldn't like because people go I'm
really open I'd look at anything and
then you start to put opportunities in
front of them they're like no no no I
said I thought you were open to anything
so actually saying what do you not want
as opposed to what do you want